I would do anything for a baby now we're
at the point where we need to move on to
the other options we discussed you're
talking about surrogacy yes we work with
an excellent agency so good luck okay
sometimes nature can't make the miracle
of life happen and that's where we come
in are you mr. and mrs. Thompson you
must be Kaylee Kaylee Richmond oh my god
okay hold it of course you her parents
you want beautiful just like a mother
[Music]
surprised
can I see our little girl she called
Sophie ours Josh not yours and mine
[Music]
Oh what am i get up to do I'll get a bad
town what do you think you're doing I
don't know I guess I feel like you guys
could be a little more grateful
that's everything I did do we have a
reason to be concerned
I thoroughly vet my candidates I can
assure you that she was in our house I
understand that sir this isn't some
stranger's she keeps coming back trying
to see our daughter I wouldn't surprised
me she had a very strong mother who was
a outsized influence in her life she has
been harassing us she's a stalker are
you saying she's been listening to our
conversations that is exactly one thing
she's been released white she was
released in the custody of her mother
her mother
she's right where she's so sweet oh my
god
your Kaylee's mother and you oh baby
this is crazy
[Music]
this is what a mother does her daughter
no this is
you